[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal
Richtung
bilder aus der Stadt borotjanka rund 50
km von Kiew entfernt
guten Abend zum heute journal
Bundeskanzler Scholz warnte ja gestern
schon das Bilder der Zerstörung und
Bilder von Toten und Verletzten nur der
Anfang sein von dem was wahrscheinlich
noch kommt das ist also noch schlimmer
wird und so ist es die russische Armee
zerschießt weiter ukrainische Städte und
Dörfer Gebäude werden zerstört Menschen
sterben lass uns dann Informationen und
Bildern erreicht die wir so gut es geht
überprüfen zeigen sarattacke und Samuel
Kirsch
19 Jahre Biathlet mit dem Gewehr wollte
er in den sportlichen Wettkampf dann
griff Putin an er musste an die Front
hier nach Haake sein Vaterland die
Ukraine verteidigen morgen in einer
Woche wäre Jeff ja niemalischheft 20
Jahre alt geworden helden sterben nicht
schreibt der ukrainische biathlonverband
heute zu seinem Tod und doch sterben
viele auch heute wieder und auch wieder
in Racke zweitgrößte Stadt der Ukraine
und wohl eines der Hauptziele Putins
Angriffe aus der Luft und mit Raketen
vier Menschen werden getötet 10 können
verletzt gerettet werden
Luftangriffe auch auf die Stadt skito
mir rund 140 km von der Hauptstadt Kiew
entfernt Wohngebäude und ein
krankenhaussein getroffen worden zu der
Bürgermeister
zwei Menschen sterben
ich habe meine Frau verloren sie war das
Licht meines Lebens das Beste was mir
passieren konnte aber jetzt muss ich
mich zusammenreißen ich habe noch Eltern
und eine Tochter
von Norden marschieren jetzt wohl
außerdem Putins berüchtigte
tschetschenische Kämpfer in Richtung
Hauptstadt in Richtung Kiew sie gelten
als besonders brutal
Putins Truppen ziehen die Schlinge um
Kiew immer enger und noch immer fliehen
aus Kiel viele Menschen mit Hab und Gut
über zerstörte Brücken
die die bleiben suchen Schutz im
Untergrund in Kiews U-Bahn-Schächten
seit Tagen schützen sich hier vor Bomben
und Raketenangriffen ihr Bürgermeister
spricht ihnen auch heute wieder Mut zu
wir machen uns bereit und wir werden
unsere Stadt verteidigen
[Musik]
geht der Dauerbeschuss weiter Angriffe
unter anderem auf die Hafenstadt Mario
Pohl
Krankenhaus viele können nicht mal auf
den Straßen und aus den Häusern gerettet
werden sagt der Bürgermeister außerdem
sei die Wasserversorgung ausgefallen und
dann wird in diesen Wahnsinn hinein ein
Leben geboren ich
bin den Ärzten so dankbar die mir bei
der Geburt geholfen haben unter diesen
Umständen ich glaube daran dass alles
gut wird
Glauben hoffen kämpfen an vielen Orten
in der Ukraine wird mobilisiert Männer
zwischen 18 und 60 Jahren machen sich
bereit der Widerstand groß
auch hier vor dem größten Atomkraftwerk
der Ukraine im Südosten des Landes des
Mitarbeiter leisten hartnäckig
Widerstand doch mittlerweile heißt es
aus Moskau man habe den Meiler unter
russische Kontrolle gebracht Widerstand
auch im Norden in konnte keiner aufgeben
die russischen Angreifer hatten sie vor
die Wahl gestellt weichen oder
Waffengewalt ihr Bürgermeister fragt sie
wer ist fürs kämpfen
alle Antworten kämpfen kämpfen kämpfen
und das tun die Ukraine mit Waffen und
auch wie hier heute unbewaffnet mit
bloßen Händen und eisernen Willen
versuchen Sie dieses Militärfahrzeug
aufzuhalten
bis heute ja ich glaube bis heute
Nachmittag noch selbst in Kiew drin und
sind jetzt ungefähr 70 km weiter
gefahren was was hat Sie dazu bewogen
also der einzige Grund war dass wenn in
Kiew wirklich die gesamte Infrastruktur
zusammengeschossen wird und es hat sich
ja mit dem Angriff auf den Fernsehturm
angedeutet ohne Strom können Sie keine
Live-Schaltung und kein Fernsehen machen
daher wir brauchen einfach
Bewegungsfreiheit und eine gewisse
technischen Mindeststandard daher haben
wir uns jetzt einmal 70 km von Kiew
abgesetzt auf eine strategisch
eigentlich wichtigen Punkt den man
rechnet damit dass sie auch eine
Luftlandung der Russen erfolgen könnte
wenn es darum geht Kiefer von Süden
einzuschließen
demnächst losgeht was hören Sie dazu
welche Informationen haben Sie darüber
also erstens einmal wir haben heute am
Abend bereits einen Angriff wieder auf
einen Bahnhof in Kiew gehabt und wenn
sie sich das Ganze russisches Szenario
Anschauen von Beginn der Kämpfe des
hören Beschlusses am 17 februar bis hin
zu Anerkennung der sogenannten
Separatisten Gebiete und so weiter und
so fort ist das eine
Eskalationsspirale wir haben jetzt Kaki
im Osten mariopold in amazonischen
Meeres Beispiel was der Hauptstadt droht
wenn die nicht einlenken und da werden
die Russen sicher weitermachen in dieser
Richtung und das ist die große Gefahr
eben für die Millionenstadt kieft das
auch hier wirklich massive bombards
einsetzen
da tief ist natürlich eine große Stadt
und in Kiew gibt es bisher relativ wenig
Zerstörungen also kein Vergleich mit mit
Karl kiff kein Vergleich mit mariopol
aber
was nicht leider muss man sagen was
nicht ist kann noch werden wir haben
natürlich viele Zerstörungen auf anderen
Städten gesehen oder in anderen Städten
gesehen aber hier falls Zentrum ist
davon noch verschont geblieben aber es
ist auch die symbolische Bedeutung für
den Krieg für das Halten oder das
verlieren und daher wird wohl hier der
entscheidende Kampf sich abspielen
also das was eigentlich wirklich
beunruhigend ist und was erschütternd
ist erinnert alles Anton jetzt kommt die
Ausdruck keine 2014 im Kiew haben sie
eine Unmenge an Straßensperren das muss
man sich vorstellen sind so Betonblöcke
dann haben wir da den passansäcke statt
stehen vier fünf meistens junge Buam
oder Jungs mit
Kalaschnikows und einer gelben Armbinde
die machen dann eine Ausweiskontrolle
dann kann man durchfahren weiterfahren
wenn die Ausweise passen und so geht's
ein bisschen jedes Dorf denn durch die
territorial Verteidigung und durch die
Ausgabe von Waffen und freiwilligen
Verbände haben sie eine enorme
Bewaffnung jetzt auch in der Bevölkerung
von Leuten von denen eigentlich nicht
wissen was weiß der von einer
Kalaschnikow weißt du ja damit umzugehen
und so geht's im Schritt um Schritt
bisschen jedes Dorf bis wohin sie dann
kommen wie wir jetzt nach Bella circa
das ist der eine Punkt das zweite ist
sie sehen große Schlangen vor Apotheken
Lebensmittel nein natürlich auch die
Versorgung kritisch wird
aus der Ukraine und von ihnen alles Gute
danke schön
vor einer halben Stunde aufgezeichnet
und zeigen jetzt Eindrücke und
Geschichten aus der Ukraine die Reporter
der britischen BBC gedreht haben Paul
laguerin und Sarah rainsford unser
Korrespondent Andreas Stamm hat sie für
uns bearbeitet und übersetzt
die Straßen verweist das einzige
Geräusch die Warnung vor dem nächsten
Bombenangriff
Leben in Kiew heißt Leben unter Tage der
Gang in den Bunker für Lilia und ihre
beiden Töchter Routine eine Woche Krieg
hat tiefe Spuren hinterlassen
am zweiten Tag sind die Mädchen
aufgewacht und haben Lego Pistolen
gebaut um die Feinde zu töten
die älteste hat das Tanzen völlig
vergessen sie müssten jetzt Menschen
umbringen
von nichts als Turnen und tanzen habe
die fünfeinhalbjährige Victoria
gesprochen nun ist sie verstummt
stark sein für ihre Mädchen Lilia sagt
sich das immer wieder
wenn alle Kinder hier unten die
Nationalhymne Mitsingen selbst die
Jüngsten dann verliere ich die Kontrolle
ich will aber nicht dass meine Kinder
mich so sehen sie bekommen Angst und
Weinen mit mir
ein Leben im Bunker wollen sie ihren
Familien ersparen verzweifelte Väter am
Bahnhof die nipro
ein letztes ich liebe dich 400 km
östlich der Hauptstadt sind noch keine
russischen Truppen doch sie werden wohl
kommen
ich schicke meine Familie Richtung
besseres Leben
der Preis
Tränen der Angst dass sie sich nie
wieder sehen werden denn viele die gehen
besten flüchten fürchten einen Abschied
für immer
ich habe nichts mehr
nach 56 Jahren in dieser Stadt weiß ich
nicht mal ob ich zurückkommen werde
im Bunker und der Kiew fiebert Olena
ihrem vierten Geburtstag entgegen dass
sie kein Geschenk bekomme sei okay sagt
sie ihrer Mutter sie können es ja
besorgen wenn der Krieg vorbei sei
am Ende kann Putin vermutlich nur von
innen gestoppt werden von seinen eigenen
Leuten seinen eigenen System ob das je
geschieht weiß man nicht es lohnt sich
aber auf mögliche Absetzbewegungen der
Eliten zu achten interessant könnte da
die Nachricht sein dass der
milliardenschwere Olli garch Roman
Abramowitsch den Londoner Fußballclub
Chelsea verkauft der Gewinn soll über
eine Stiftung den Opfern des Krieges in
der Ukraine zugute kommen das ist
allerdings ziemlich kryptisch formuliert
da muss man noch abwarten wie das
tatsächlich gemeint ist
fest steht dass es Proteste in Russland
gibt aus der Intelligenz ja aus der
Zivilgesellschaft culine ataybericht
nur noch ein Rauschen ist zu hören auf
der Welle auf der über 30 Jahre lang
Radio echommerski ausgestrahlt wurde der
einzig verbliebene landesweite
Chefredakteur Alex
Verfassung verboten
ich bin überrascht immer noch überrascht
nein das hatte absolut niemand erwartet
wir haben noch ein paar unabhängige
Medien aber ich glaube sie stehen auch
vor dem Aus
inzwischen ist ein weiteres
Online-Medium blockiert ein weiterer
Hörfunksender hat beschlossen seine
Sendungen einzustellen weil er so
wirklich nicht lügen will als
Regionalzeitungen gestern dieser
Wahnsinn muss gestoppt werden auf den
Titel Seiten brachten wurden sie
beschlagnahmt
ich finde das ungeheuerlich das sind
doch die Überreste einer freien Stimme
die erstickt wurden
wahrscheinlich sagen sie zu viel von dem
was nicht gewünscht wird
gestern verhaftete die Polizei zwei
Mütter und ihre fünf Kinder die Blumen
niederlegen wollten an der ukrainischen
Botschaft sie trugen Plakate mit der
Aufschrift kein Krieg den Eltern wird
gedroht die Vormundschaft für die Kinder
zu entziehen
trotzdem findet der Proteste bürgerwege
sich auszudrücken der Slogan kein Krieg
schmückt inzwischen Häuserwände
Bushaltestellen Balkongeländer und
Fahrstühle auch wenn er schnell übermalt
wird
wollen wir noch nachfragen bei unserem
Korrespondenten in Moskau Christiansen
Christian ist heißt dass es jetzt auch
Protest von den sogenannten Soldaten
Müttern gibt die ja doch eine erhebliche
Rolle spielen können in diesem Land
genau das Komitee für Soldatenmütter
eine Menschenrechtsorganisation einer
der wenigen die es in Russland noch gibt
die berichten von verzweifelten Anrufen
von Müttern die und Briefen Briefe
kriegen sie auch einige die den Kontakt
zu ihren Söhnen verloren haben die nicht
wissen wo sie sind die kein
Lebenszeichen mehr bekommen
und es heißt weiter dass viele dieser
jungen Menschen in den Krieg gezogen
sind und gar nicht wussten dass es ein
Krieg ist also dass sie weiter davon
ausgehen dass es sich um eine
Militärübung handelt und dann nach
dieser Militärübung als sie eigentlich
beendet werden sollte dann im Krieg
gelandet sind und Kritik kommt heute
auch von einer hier sehr bekannten
Senatoren Ludmilla
narutova ich kann sie kurz mal zitieren
sie sagt nämlich sie identifiziert sich
überhaupt nicht mehr mit dem Verhalten
der Behörden die für den Krieg sind denn
was sie tun wissen sie ihrer Meinung
nach selbst nicht und sie würden nur
Befehle Bef und denken nicht darüber
nach was sie tun
heute gab es ja erstmals auch Zahlen
Totenzahlen die veröffentlicht wurden in
Russland auch das ist selten 498 das ist
die offizielle Zahl die Ukraine spricht
von mehreren tausend Toten und diese
Stimme der Senatoren und die sozusagen
die Meldung des Komitees der Soldaten
Mütter das ist offene Kritik die man in
Russland sonst so offen nicht hört
die Frage nach einer Wahl nee es ist ja
immer das Problem der Opposition ist im
Moment das ist kein gibt der sie
organisiert aber er scheint es zu
schaffen sich aus dem Straflager in dem
man sich befindet heraus doch zu melden
ja er hat das in der Vergangenheit immer
wieder geschafft vor allem über
Instagram und über andere Social Media
Plattformen er schafft das über seine
Anwälte die dann seine Botschaften in
den Netzwerken verbreiten und er hat
heute dazu aufgerufen dass die Russin
und Russen ab jetzt jeden Tag um 19 Uhr
auf die Plätze ihre Städte gehen sollen
und demonstrieren wir haben heute Abend
in Moskau nachgeschaut in Moskau haben
wir den Eindruck wird das alles im Keim
erstickte Moskau Bürgermeister hat ja
auch angekündigt das Proteste nicht
zugelassen werden wir haben viele
Polizisten gesehen viele Absperrungen
und da war Prozent an Protest nicht
möglich in St Petersburg sind wohl
einige hundert auf die Straße gegangen
und nach neuesten Zahlen heißt es das am
Abend über 700 Menschen schon
festgenommen wurden also naval nie
versucht das auch aus dem Straflager
raus ob sich daraus etwas entwickelt das
müssen wir in den nächsten Tagen
beobachten
derweil haben die Ukraine auch viel
Angst um das Leben ihres Präsidenten der
die Moral eines ganzen Volkes hoch hält
und ja auch laufend mit der Außenwelt
kommuniziert die Ironie des Schicksals
ist da sie wurde die mir selenski in
seinem früheren Leben als Schauspieler
und Humorist bereits die Rolle des
Präsidenten spielte dieser tierische
Fernsehserie Diener des Volkes war 2015
in der Ukraine ein Riesenerfolg mit
deutschen Untertiteln ist sie in der
Mediathek von ARTE abrufbar und findet
dort jetzt auch wachsendes Interesse in
einer Szene telefoniert der tv-präsident
mit Angela Merkel und glaubt
fälschlicherweise sie biete ihm die
EU-Präsidentschaft an die
EU-Mitgliedschaft
den Ausschnitt wollen wir Ihnen zeigen
nicht um zu ereitern sie ist im
Rückblick eigentlich eher schmerzlich
weil sie uns Deutschen Zuschauern so
klar vor Augen führt wie sehr sich die
westlich orientierten Ukrainer schon
seit langem die offenen Arme Europas
gewünscht haben
[Musik]
ja
mann mann
Montenegro nice okay
ulations
verance
[Musik]
meine Formulierung aus dem jüdischen zu
verwenden der Präsident als wahrer
Mensch
CNN Interview sagte er gestern der Krieg
findet zwar in seinem Land statt aber es
gehe dabei um weit mehr als die Ukraine
diese Botschaft scheint den großen
Teilen der Welt angekommen zu sein die
Vollversammlung der Vereinten Nationen
hat heute mit einer unerwartet großen
Mehrheit einer Resolution zugestimmt die
den russischen Angriff verurteilt nur
fünf Staaten einschließlich Russland
stimmten dagegen das ist wirklich
bemerkenswert aus New York Johannes
Hanau
am Ende war das Ergebnis dann doch sehr
viel eindeutiger als vieles vermutet
hatten 141 Staaten stimmten für die
Resolution die Russlands Einmarsch in
die Ukraine verurteilt und Russland
auffordert seine Truppen sofort
zurückzuziehen Russland und seine
engsten Freunde Weißrussland Syrien
Eritrea und Nordkorea stimmt dagegen
die heutige Resolution reflektiert eine
zentrale Wahrheit die Welt will ein Ende
dieses furchtbaren Leids in der Ukraine
praktisch in letzter Minute hat auch
Deutschland noch einmal sein ganzes
diplomatisches Gewicht in die Waagschale
geworfen und die Außenministerin
geschickt um die zu überzeugen die sich
noch unschlüssig waren
Russlands Krieg markiert eine neue
Realität die verlangt von jedem
Einzelnen von uns eine klare und
verantwortungsvolle Entscheidung zu
treffen und sich für eine Seite zu
entscheiden
war Russlands Angriff auf die Ukraine
geht es um sehr viel mehr so die
Außenministerin ist sei ein Angriff auf
die Kater der Vereinten Nationen und die
Weltordnung diese repräsentieren
russland hat diese Weltordnung brutal
angegriffen und deshalb geht es in
diesem Krieg nicht nur um die Ukraine
es ist ein Wendepunkt
und sie macht den eindringlichen Worten
klar was dieser Krieg bedeutet
es geht um Leben oder Tod des
ukrainischen Volkes es geht um die
Sicherheit Europas was auf dem Spiel
steht ist die Kater der Vereinten
Nationen fast jedes in diesem Raum
vertretene Land hat einen größeren
mächtigeren Nachbarn es geht um uns alle
this is about Olivers
zum Schluss gab es was in der
Generalversammlung so gut wie nie
vorkommen Beifall für eine Rede die von
vielen Diplomaten als außergewöhnlich
stark betrachtet wurde am Abend hatte
auch der amerikanische Präsidentin
Anwesenheit der ukrainischen Botschaft
darin in seiner Rede an die Nation vor
dem US-Kongress eine klare Ansage
Richtung Wladimir Putin gemacht
er hat gedacht der Westen und die NATO
wird nicht antworten er hat gedacht er
könnte uns Spalten hier zu Hause in
dieser Kammer unsere Nation er dachte
auch er könnte uns von Europa spalten
aber Putin liegt falsch wir sind bereit
wir sind vereint und wir bleiben vereint
Einigkeit und großer Applaus von
Demokraten und Republikanern russland
hat etwas erreicht was es in den USA
schon lange nicht mehr gegeben hat
nach der Abstimmung in den Vereinten
Nationen heute wurde dann klar Russland
ist nach seinem Einmarsch in der Ukraine
auch im Rest der Welt weitgehend
isoliert allerdings haftet der
Resolution ein schweres Manko an die
beiden Atommächte und
bevölkerungsreichsten Länder der Welt
indien und China haben sich der Stimme
enthalten
Player wollen wir sehen denn es lohnt
sich in diesem Konflikt auf diesen
besonderen Player auf der Weltbühne zu
blicken auf China China wie gesagt hat
sich bei der uno-abstimmung heute
erstmal enthalten und Fräulein Peking
wie ist die chinesische Perspektive auf
diesen Krieg und seine Folgen
ich glaube dass die chinesische
Regierung zunehmend nervös wird und über
den Verlauf des Krieges absolut
unzufrieden ist der Krieg dauert zu
lange es gibt zu viele zivile Tote und
vor allem und das ist das Wichtigste für
China wird die Weltwirtschaft sehr in
Mitleidenschaft gezogen die chinesische
Regierung befürchtet dass die Sanktion
gegen Russland irgendwann auch auf China
ausstrahlen werden und es dann eben hier
auf die Wirtschaft ausschlägt und dann
gibt es eben noch ein großes
strategisches Dilemma das Ziel der
chinesischen Regierung eigentlich der
letzten Jahre ist gewesen die westliche
Welt zu spalten Europa von Amerika
abzuspalten und durch diesen Krieg den
ja China nicht als Krieg bezeichnet
sondern als spezialoperation von
Russland ist es eben gelungen Putin am
die NATO quasi wach zu küssen und das
westliche Bündnis wiederzubeleben also
Europa Amerika sind so eng wie noch nie
rüsten auf und das will China überhaupt
nicht deshalb versucht China hinter den
Kulissen stark zu vermitteln Druck auf
Russen auszuüben in irgendeiner Form
eine friedliche Lösung zu finden ob das
gelingt kann keiner sagen und vielleicht
noch ein letzter Gedanke am Ende wird
China aber nicht die Seiten wechseln es
wird zu Russland treu stehen denn es ist
wie auch schon Frau bärburg die
ausmisten gesagt hat ein Konflikt der
Systeme auf der einen Seite Chichi ping
und Putin die beiden Autokraten oder
Diktatoren auf der anderen Seite die
sogenannte freie Welt und wenn es darum
geht ob man sich für sein System
entscheiden muss auch für das Überleben
seines Systems wird sie immer für das
System entscheiden und gegen den Frieden
wenn es sein muss
über den Krieg in der Ukraine und seine
ganzen internationalen Auswirkungen
halten wir Sie natürlich auch online auf
dem Laufenden auf ZDF heute und jetzt
macht erstmal eins weiter mit den
Nachrichten Bundeskanzler Scholz war
heute zu besuchen Israel ja und auch
dabei war der Krieg in der Ukraine
zentrales Thema aber es ging auch um die
Deutsch israelischen Beziehungen Bennet
und Scholz besuchten gemeinsam die
Holocaust-Gedenkstätte jagdwaschem soll
sprach anschließend über die besondere
Verantwortung Deutschlands
Verantwortung für die Sicherheit des
Staates Israels
später auf einer Pressekonferenz äußerte
sich Scholz auch zum ukrainekrieg
wir werden nicht militärisch eingreifen
das gilt für die NATO das wird sie nicht
tun
und auch für alle anderen
auch Bennet forderte einen sofortigen
Waffenstillstand
die Verbreitung der russischen
Staatsmedien RT und Sputnik in der
Europäischen Union ist ab sofort
verboten umgesetzt werden muss diese
EU-Maßnahme jeweils in den einzelnen
Mitgliedstaaten
eu-kommissionschefin Ursula von der
Leyen sagte in Zeiten des Kriegs sein
Worte entscheidend man werde nicht
zulassen dass Kreml Treue ihre Lügen
zurechtfertigung von Putins Krieg
verbreiten
mit einer Großdemonstration ist in
München ein Zeichen für Frieden in
Europa und Solidarität mit der Ukraine
gesetzt worden 10.000 der versammelten
sich am Abend auf dem Königsplatz um
gegen den russischen Angriff auf die
Ukraine zu demonstrieren zu der
Kundgebung hatten Parteien Verbände
Gewerkschaften und
Religionsgemeinschaften aufgerufen
wenn sie den Menschen in der Ukraine und
jenen auf der Flucht helfen wollen
können Sie spenden z.B beim
Aktionsbündnis Katastrophenhilfe
Stichwort ZDF Nothilfe Ukraine IBAN
de65100 400 600-100 400 600 alle Infos
auch unter spenden.zdf.de oder im ZDF
Text auf Seite 890
lang um die russisch-deutschen
Beziehungen bemühten ein Schlag ganz
besonders für diejenigen die sich um
besonders gute Beziehungen zu Putin
behüten bei vielen brechen da gerade
Weltbilder zusammen oder auch nicht
bemerkenswert ist wie sich der manche
ganz links und ganz rechts
zusammenfinden etwa die Linke Sahra
Wagenknecht und der
Präsidentschaftskandidat der AFD Max
Otte sie twitterten wortgleich und
zeitgleich dass es ein schwerer Fehler
wäre auf der Basis von putinsforderung
nach einer endmilitarisierten Ukraine
keine Verhandlungen mit ihm zu führen
und das absolut identisch in Foto und
Text das darf man seltsam finden
nun kann man solche Auffälligkeiten
einzelner radikaler als Randnotiz
betrachten wesentlich gewichtiger ist
der Fall Gerhard Schröder während die
Europäische Union Sanktionen gegen
Russland verhängt hält der deutsche
Altkanzler an seinen einschlägigen
Geschäftsbeziehungen fest das ist nicht
nur für die SPD ein Problem gestern
hatte ich fürs heute journal einen
Interview mit dem Kremlkritiker Michael
holokowski aufgezeichnet indem er an die
Russen appellierte sich gegen Putin zu
erheben und nach der Aufzeichnung sagte
er bei der Verabschiedung mit so viel
samten Lächeln zu mir und schöne Grüße
an Herrn Schröder auch im Ausland wird
diese Angelegenheit wahrgenommen der
weil es um den Altkanzler einsam wird
Peter kunstberichtet
an ihm konnte man sich schon immer
reiben Kanzler Gerhard Schröder vereinte
hemsärmlichkeit mit teuren brionianzügen
der SPD war sein Ego nicht immer geheuer
aber er hatte sie 1998 zurückgebracht an
die Macht der Genosse der Bosse lotste
die Bundesrepublik auf einen Reformweg
der viele schmerzte und dem Land nützte
als Schröder 2005 gegen Angela Merkel
die Wahl verloren hatte Sprachen seine
neuen Bosse dann nicht mehr nur Deutsch
das promen rosnieft der Lobbyist
Schröder sammelte führungs- und
aufsichtsposten in Vladimir Putins auf
Öl und Gas gebautem Reich zwei ziemlich
beste Freunde der erste nordstream
Vertrag unterschrieben schnell noch vor
Schröders Ausscheiden aus dem Kanzleramt
diese Zusammenarbeit ist gegen niemanden
gerichtet sondern dient deutschen
Interessen und dient russischen
Interessen und ich wüsste nicht was
daran falsch sein sollte Gerhard
Schröder hält auch an Tag 7 des Angriffs
auf die Ukraine an seinem Auftraggeber
Kreml und seinen Jobs fest auf LinkedIn
schreibt er nur dass ein schnelles
Kriegsende die Verantwortung der
russischen Regierung sei Fehler habe es
aber auf beiden Seiten gegeben das ist
überfällig das Gerhard Schröder seine
Ämter bei russischen staatskonzernen
niederlegt und das soll er nicht der SPD
zu Liebe tun sondern dem Ansehen der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland in einem Jahr
mit vier Landtagswahlkämpfen ist der
gaslobbyist Schröder für die SPD toxisch
geworden nichts ist mehr unmöglich auch
nicht der Parteiausschluss des
Altkanzlers
ich habe den Eindruck mit dieser Haltung
hat er sich mindestens mal schon
innerlich von der SPD verabschiedet und
alles weitere wird man jetzt sehen er
war einmal der friedenskanzler mit
seinem mutigen nein zum Irakkrieg aber
schon mit viel Verständnis für Putin als
der die tschetschenische Hauptstadt
Grosny ohne Rücksicht auf Zivilisten in
Grund und Boden bombte ich habe gemeint
dass es in Bezug auf Tschetschenien zu
einer differenzierteren Bewertung der
Völkergemeinschaft kommen muss und sich
auch kommen wird
Putins Herrschaft in Russland begann
1999 gleich mit einem Krieg parallel
wuchs die Männerfreundschaft mit dem
deutschen Kanzler
Mütterchen Russland nahm Gerhard
Schröder eng ans Herz wie berechnet auch
immer all die Liebesgrüße aus Moskau
über die Jahre gewesen sein mögen es
bleibt jetzt die Nibelungen Treue zweier
sturer Alter weißer Männer
mit dem Blick auf die Wirtschaft und da
speziell auf den Ölpreis der hat wieder
einen Rekord hoch erreicht um den Markt
zu beruhigen hat die Bundesregierung
einen kleinen Teil der nationalen
Ölreserve freigegeben was bedeutet so
ein Schritt Frank Bethmann und was
bringt er
an die strategischen Reserven um
zumindest ein wenig den Preisdruck
rauszunehmen das ganze international
abgestimmt insgesamt bringen 31 Länder
über 60 Millionen Barrel Rohöl
zusätzlich auf den Markt doch geholfen
hat das erstmal nicht das Nordseeöl der
Marke brennt steigt weiter inzwischen
auf ein achtjahres Hoch und das Erdgas
kostet an den internationalen
Terminmärkten mittlerweile so viel wie
nie zuvor wenig hilfreich war sicher was
die OPEC plus also die 13
erdölfördernden OPEC-Mitglieder und ihre
zehn Kooperationspartner darunter
Russland am Nachmittag in Windeseile
beschlossen nämlich dass sie ihre
Produktionsmenge im April nur soweit
erhöht wie ohnehin geplant kein das
Aufdrehen der ölhähne also der
Preisanstieg damit nicht gestoppt
bemerkenswert auch russisches Öl findet
zunehmend weniger Abnehmer und obwohl es
noch keine direkten Sanktionen für
russisches Öl gibt kehren die großen
westlichen Firmen wie Shell oder BP der
russischen Ölindustrie bereits jetzt den
Rücken
vielen Dank
der umstrittene Kölner Kardinal wokim
hat den Papst überraschend seinen
Amtsverzicht Angeboten franziskus wäre
zu gegebener Zeit darüber entscheiden
teilte das Erzbistum Köln mit zunächst
hat Woelki nach 5 monatiger Auszeit
wieder die Leitung des Bistums
übernommen vor dem Kölner Dom hatte es
am Morgen Proteste gegen seine Rückkehr
gegeben welche steht wegen seines
Umgangs mit Missbrauchsfällen in der
katholischen Kirche in der Kritik in
einem Brief an die Gläubigen Bad Wolky
um eine zweite Chance auch gegenüber dem
ZDF äußerte er sich
ich habe mein Amtsverzicht den Papst
eingereicht und der Papst wird jetzt
einfach schauen wie er damit umgeht und
natürlich weiß ich dass es Menschen gibt
die sich sehr schwer mit mir tun dass es
Menschen gibt die mich auch ablehnen
aber es gibt eben auch andere Menschen
die sehr dankbar sind dass ich da bin
zum Fußball zwei ergebnisse vom
DFB-Pokal Viertelfinale am Abend
Hannover hat gegen Leipzig 0:4 verloren
die Partie Hamburg gegen Karlsruhe wurde
erst im Elfmeterschießen entschieden der
HSV gewann dieses mit drei zu zwei
das ZDF trauert um Klaus Seibel der im
Alter von 85 Jahren gestorben ist mehr
als 30 Jahre lang war er Moderator der
heute Sendung die Nachrichten des Tages
heute mit Klaus Seibel
guten Abend sein Gesicht wird in
Erinnerung bleiben so ZDF-Chefredakteur
Peter frei sein Stil zurückhaltender
Verbindlichkeit setze Maßstäbe bis heute
und jetzt die Zahlen vom Lotto am
Mittwoch sie lauten wie immer ohne
Gewähr
3515 39 44 49 Superzahl 7 weitere
Gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotto.zdf.de
und im ZDF Text auf Seite 557
das war's von unserem heute schon mal
über alle aktuellen Entwicklungen halten
wir Sie natürlich online weiter auf dem
laufenden später auch im heute schon mal
Update gegen 0:35 Uhr mit Gundula Gause
mit einem auslandsjournal Spezial weiter
unter anderem mit einer Reportage aus
Moskau über die antikriegsprotestern
Russland auf Wiedersehen auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend es ist eben ganz
entscheidend wo das Hoch liegt wenn es
nämlich nördlich von uns liegt dann
kommt hier mit einer nordöstlichen
Strömung die Kälte heran und da kalten
Luft deutlich weniger Feuchtigkeit
aufnehmen kann als warme kommt dann auch
mal Nebel und Hochnebel mit das passiert
auch wieder in dieser Nacht sonst ist es
meist sternenklar hier im Südwesten
gibt's noch ein paar dichtere
Wolkenfelder die Temperaturen sinken auf
bloß ein Grad auf den Ostfriesischen
Inseln und bis -9° z.B im Thüringer Wald
und morgen liegen die Höchsttemperaturen
am Alpenrand am Main am Rhein und lässt
dich davon bei frühlingsmilben 10 bis 14
Grad meist sind es aber nur 6 bis 9 Grad
und hier in der Ostsee bleibt es bei
drei bis fünf Grad sogar noch kälter das
liegt eben an dieser nord-ostströmung
und daran dass sich dort Nebel und
Hochnebel durchaus mal ganz zäh halten
können zum Beispiel in der Lübecker
Bucht könnte es bis zum Abend trüb
bleiben sonst aber strahlt die Sonne und
mit diesem Wetter haben wir es gleich
auch noch Freitag und Samstag zu tun das
Hoch ändert seine Lage kaum und die
kalte Luft kommt nach wie vor aus
Richtung Nordosten zu unseren allenfalls
Richtung Erzgebirge ist es nicht völlig
ausgeschlossen dass da mal eine kleine
Schneeflocke fällt die Tiefs aber die
bleiben alle auf Abstand und so geht's
auch in den nächsten Tagen im Westen
viel Sonne im Osten etwas mehr Wolken
und Nebel und etwas tieferer
Temperaturen guten Abend